bei uns im studio ist ins bild live chef
claus strunz claus guth er sich mit
morgen erst wurde einiges gesagt einiges
besprochen materiell es wurde aber auch
über einiges vor allem ein sehr
wichtiges thema für dieses land gar
nicht gesprochen ja absolut
irritierend dass in einer zeit in der
wieder viele menschen nämlich aus
afghanistan nach deutschland kommen was
ja frei bei den bei den bürgern bei
vielen menschen im land dieses
gedächtnis auslöst an 2015 kommen da die
richtigen kommen die die wir holen
wollen kommen menschen die wir hier gar
nicht haben wollen das alles ist ja im
raum und ich verstehe die die sorgen der
menschen und hätte mir schon erwartet
dass die kandidaten antworten geben
müssen auf diese frage wer kommt denn da
in den flugzeugen aus kabul wer sind die
leute die da ihre
zukunft in deutschland suchen es gab ja
große appelle und ganz viele menschen
die auch skeptisch waren sind den
appellen gern gefolgt weil es hieß es
kommen ortskräfte ortskräfte steht ja
für menschen die uns deutschen den
westlichen
soldaten in afghanistan in den letzten
jahren geholfen haben das land sozusagen
dem zu demokratisieren das ist jetzt
fehl geschlagen und die sorge ist dass
diese menschen dort auf rache treffen
und möglicherweise sogar mit ihrem leben
bezahlen müssen jeder der ein herz im
leib hat wird sagen diesen menschen muss
man helfen und diesen menschen muss man
zuflucht geben aber sind eigentlich
diese menschen denen wir helfen wollen
in den flugzeugen gewesen da tauchen
große fragen auf ihm kein wort dazu als
hätte man ist sozusagen angst die
wahrheit zu sagen denn von den über
3.000 die allein von deutschland
ausgeflogen wurden sind dar angaben der
bundesregierung des
bundesinnenministeriums nur rund 100
tatsächlich diese ortskräfte auf diese
zahlen hast du dich gerade bezogen und
hast du ja schon mal selber so ein
kanzlerduell
damals mit moderiert du weißt wie das da
im vorfeld läuft also wird ein
bestimmtes gezielt ausgeklammert sagt er
möglicherweise der eine oder andere
kandidat nun lasst mal lasst mal lieber
übers ländern über klima reden als über
die lästige flüchtlingsfrage nein ich
habe es nicht so erlebt ich habe gibt
das die fragesteller die themen die
ihnen wichtig sind fragen konnten daraus
liegt der schluss nahe dass ist
sozusagen den gestrigen fragestellern
keine frage wert war sondern die
menschen weiter belehrt worden sind über
klima das würde bedeuten mir eingeredet
das klima das thema nummer eins der
menschen ist ich kenne wirklich wenig
elektriker oder
tapezierer oder
menschen die in kindergärten arbeiten
oder krankenschwestern die von früh bis
spät darüber nachdenken ob sie sich
jetzt ein elektroauto kaufen sollen weil
das für die umwelt gute sich kennen
hingegen ganz viele leute die sich
sorgen machen wohin dieses land geht
wenn immer mehr menschen zu uns kommen
und eine andere kultur mitbringen und du
nennst der die zahl ich habe nochmal
neue mitgebracht 4100 afghanische
staatsbürger sind bisher ausgeflogen
worden du hast genannt um die 100 das
stimmt um die 100 da ist es sicher dass
es kräfte sind und das sind noch mal 370
ihre angehörigen dabei also 400 leute
470 500 leute das sind ungefähr 13
prozent derer die jetzt angekommen sind
in deutschland aber wer sind die anderen
87 prozent und auch da gibt es
interessante informationen hinter den
kulissen immer wenn die
regierungsvertreter sich untereinander
verhalten und miteinander reden kommt
was zum vorschein von dem wir finden es
muss eigentlich die öffentlichkeit es
kommt aber erst mal nicht an die
öffentlichkeit denn da haben sie
festgestellt dass
mehrere männer dabei waren mit
gefälschten papieren und es sind sogar
jetzt schon vier straftäter dingfest
gemacht worden die in dem flugzeug waren
darunter zwei vergewaltiger man muss
auch sagen niemand bei dem sozusagen das
radar angeht ein terrorverdächtiger zu
sein trotzdem ich glaube man muss heute
sagen liebe regierung wehrte regierung
klärt bitte so schnell wie möglich auf
wer die menschen in diesen flugzeugen
sind damit die leute im land die diesen
rettungsflug unterstützt haben die
gesagt haben ja wir müssen die
ortskräfte retten reinen wein
eingeschenkt bekommen und wenn wir
wieder feststellen dass leute gekommen
sind deren identität wenn dich kennen
dass leute gekommen sind mit gefälschten
papieren wenn leute gekommen sind mit
gefälschten dann stelle ich die frage
sind vielleicht auch leute gekommen die
die taliban schicken wollten mit den
fliegern und all diese fragen stehen im
raum und die regierung heiko maas und
auch die kanzlerin müssen diese fragen
beantworten und zwar klipp und klar
[Musik]